Sí el general Mark milley que es el jefe
del Estado Mayor conjunto de Estados
Unidos
calificó estos ataques por parte de
Putin como crímenes de guerra no es la
primera vez que altos oficiales del
pentágono se refieren a las acciones de
Ucrania como crímenes de guerra dijo
textualmente el general Mark milley que
pues Rusia trató de afectar a
infraestructura civil trató de afectar a
los ciudadanos a mujeres a niños a
personas adultas y que esto pues es
simplemente un crimen de guerra estas
declaraciones las hizo Marc Miley en
Bruselas en el marco de una reunión
donde más de 50 países están reunidos
para tratar de reunir precisamente más
ayuda militar a Ucrania de Cara a la
defensa de estos avances que hace
Vladimir Putin en Ucrania y Cristóbal el
presidente de también reaccionó cuáles
fueron sus palabras
Sí y reaccionó después de que hubiera
dicho que Vladimir Putin calculó mal la
respuesta de Ucrania en en su intento de
Invasión a ese país y David después de
haber dicho también hace unas horas de
que no creía que al fin de cuentas a
Vladimir Putin iba a usar armas
nucleares en su país pues reaccionó
entonces a la salida de la Casa Blanca
en su viaje a Los Ángeles y dijo que era
simplemente brutal y que estaba por
encima de los límites lo que estaba
haciendo Vladimir Putin con estos
recientes ataques en Ucrania donde hasta
el momento se han calculado ya 20
muertos dijo el presidente Yo bailén
también en estos intercambios que ha
tenido con los medios de comunicación
que no se quería referir nuevamente a la
respuesta de Estados Unidos en caso de
que Rusia y Vladimir Putin decidieran
usar armas nucleares precisamente para
escalar más las tensiones en cuanto a
este tema y La retórica en el en el
amenaza nuclear que ya habla de mil
Putin ha usado de alguna manera como
herramienta de guerra al verse
arrinconado como lo muestran reportes de
los avances ucranianos en su territorio